you host this show Hollywood game night
10 and it's a lot of time it's a really
fun show and the one thing I heard and I
was even wondering like is this
something people do on television
because we've never done it here is that
you encourage people to drink you
encourage contestants to drink we used
to you used to yes okay I've been on a
couple times in both times they just
pour the blade oh yeah in addition to
what you came with me
[Laughter]
we used to anyway for the first few
seasons we would every time the glass
was empty they would fill it up a people
god drunk you had some drunk we had a
bad guy in the celebrities celebrities
celebrities oh yeah and you name names I
will not I just have to guess then yeah
you'll have to get you know in the fetal
position this one woman a lot of guy yes
we around it when she got into the fetal
position she was crying because she she
lost the point for the and she felt bad
and she like went into the fetal
position and tears and and then so what
we had Blanchett no yes exactly okay and
then we have altars stand up anymore and
then we had a one celebrity give a huge
speech about how hard it is to find a
good nanny to our audience nothing bonds
you to a crowd wow that's really related